I'm missing my opportunity if I don't do
it so I just rubbed my head like that
instead of moving in electron what can I
do in half an hour so that I can print
it and send it tomorrow because this is
his chance quick so
you will be laughing when I tell you
what was there or I heard the theory of
Eternal chaotic inflation wow in a half
an hour yes unbelievable any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
welcome everybody to a very special
episode of the into the impossible
podcast I am your formerly fearful host
Brian Keating who started the podcast
three years ago in a time of pandemic
when I wanted to speak to the world's
most Brilliant Minds and and explain
some of their ideas and bring to your
attention so that you may ask them
questions and today is no exception we
have Professor Andre Linde of Stanford
University and Andre I couldn't resist
this it's kind of mandatory now to ask
chat GPT about all these things and it
got most of it right it did say however
that you uh wrote co-wrote the book
um uh Faith fantasy and fiction
um but that's that's not right that was
Roger Penrose past guest on the show but
otherwise it's pretty good Andre
dimitrovich Linde is a russian-american
theoretical physicist and the Harold
trap freeze professor of physics at
Stanford University he's one of the main
authors in architect of inflation or
universe as well as the theory of
chaotic inflation Eternal inflation and
the inflationary Multiverse does that
sound about right Andre
very good well I've been uh really
having a great desire to have you on the
podcast for a couple of years now and
our schedules have worked out finally so
we can record this uh In This Very
auspicious month the place so uh it's a
pleasure to welcome you to the podcast
thank you for being here
thank you for inviting me
so we exchanged uh a couple of a dozen
emails about different things and we
also had uh the wonderful opportunity
When Alan Lightman was a guest on the
podcast for his second appearance on the
Transcendent Brain Episode I'll put a
link to that somewhere up here
um you were kind enough to ask him some
questions and so The Story Goes
turnabout is fair play so we're gonna
have some questions from Alan Lightman
coming up later but before we do that we
love to do a segment on this podcast
called judging books by their covers
[Music]
and oftentimes there's not much to go on
uh but I think in the case of your book
uh particle physics and inflationary
cosmology there'll be a lot to discuss
we'll show a picture of it on the screen
right now uh it's this magical black uh
cover that I don't know what it's
supposed to represent but Andre how did
you come why did you write that book you
know that that particular book
uh well uh you know I was in a strange
situation at that time
um
it it I started writing it somewhere in
85 so when inflationary cosmology it
seemed that it is already done
everything is clear uh the uh well the
first one was old inflation new
inflation and finally my theory
cancellation and then it was clear for
me the the general picture already have
it okay so it's necessary to explain
what we have because of what was already
at that time was completely magical
uh on the other hand I hate writing
books I research
and so I it was impossible for me to uh
just to stop doing what I was doing and
to summarize and ever
each time it was possible to be
a kind of
diverted into some different direction
and do some other piece of research
however
something changed in year 85 86
because you know I I was in Russia at
that time and they have special rules
for us publishing papers
and the rule was that before sending a
paper for publication you need to first
get permission from academic Sciences
then to send the request for permission
to some other agency which would check
that I would not reveal any secrets of
the the universe which would help the
importance for whatever okay so each
time it took us like three months but
then Gorbachev came to power and they
decided to simplify everything it was
called prehistorical to remove all
bureaucratic obstacles on our way Etc so
removed they just stopped this agency
from functioning
there was no agency which would be
supposed to ask a permission and
therefore essentially we were living
with a mouse so if we were able to write
something it was only in Russian
journals which will be translated a year
later okay so this would put us in a
strong disadvantage and okay then that's
the time to start writing book so that
was how it started enormously
and nevertheless uh in the uh in in 86
something else happened because I was
because of all of these and some other
circumstances like I was learning for
first time how to drive my car and
Moscow ice and my instructor told me
what he thinks about my talents in
special kind of Russian which you cannot
find in the books all of this together I
kind of got depressed and so I was
laying on the bed I could not do much
whatever all doctors told me that I'm
completely healthy okay but that's how
it was and then suddenly they called me
or sorry for such a long story but
that's how it was okay suddenly there
was a call from Academy of Sciences
saying that you must go to Italy huh the
time it was absolutely impossible uh and
uh only one visit per year in the best
case allowed and now where should I go
to read popular lectures of astronomy to
citizens of Rome whatever something
totally weird so probably there was some
agreement between academies
and they don't know I cannot go so I use
my only Opera to go for this formal
thing and uh they told me well uh give
us a certificate that you cannot go
and they understood that it was serious
so I I did not went to my wife went to a
level of Institute to get something
signed by our head of theory division
Ginsburg and he left he said what the
problem she doesn't want to go abroad it
doesn't go abroad so he signed something
for that in a few days later there was
another call saying well today you say
you are ill but tomorrow you'll be
healthy if you just cannot go abroad
then just tell it to us
and that was already very dangerous so I
picked up some documents so long story
short
they required for me to send them a new
paper for publication to be distributed
among citizens of Rome and turina
whatever
and usually it takes a lot of time but
now it was hopeless because there is
nowhere to get permission
but they would send it there with
diplomatic mail without any permissions
required
so it was like a shock for me and when
do you need it I asked and they told me
better tomorrow
wow and now how would it go okay so it
is totally uh
totally insane especially in my state at
that time a kind of ill whatever and I
understood on the other hand there are
missing my opportunity if I don't do it
so I just rubbed my head like that
instead of moving in Direction what can
I do in half an hour so that I can print
it and send it tomorrow because this is
your chance
yeah you will be laughing when I tell
you what was that or I have the theory
of Eternal chaotic inflation wow in a
half an hour yes unbelievable but I
wasn't able to write it at that time
uh so I sent them some nonsense uh but
nevertheless a month later when I was on
the way to Rome Etc I held in my luggage
well not allowed three papers on Eternal
inflation which I took with me wow and
after that when I returned I was
healthier
and after that I understood that I must
rewrite everything which I have written
in my book
and that's how the book was so it was
delayed from from the original
publication from 1986.
um I I thought that I'm going to publish
it maybe 96. I've written a half of it
and glue because there is no computer
used right so it was not a very optimal
way to do things and then when in middle
of that you understand that you should
actually change it completely right so
it was wow I mean from my perspective of
multi your Multiverse in chaotic
inflation just a quick pause to ask you
for a small favor while my thumb is
occupied with old Albert on it yours is
presumably freed up to leave a thumbs up
on this video really helps me a lot with
it good old-fashioned YouTube algorithm
thanks a lot now back to the video me
now I remember reading in 1988 89 I
think it was 88 when Stephen Hawking's A
Brief History of Time came out and
you're mentioned in that book quite
extensively and it's not a surprise
maybe why chat GPT thinks that you might
have written it or something else but
around that time there was this new
field meeting or something was the new
field meeting was that before the book
came out or after it was long before it
was actually the first meeting on
inflation in 84 in Cambridge but before
and that was him
in Moscow in 81 and you had been working
on a lecture week phase Transitions and
and so forth when did you start you know
when did you did you ever consider
yourself a cosmologist until that point
or were you did you consider yourself a
high energy theorist what was your self
notion about what you worked on well I
thought that I'm going to do uh
six
but then it just will
the flow of events moved me to cosmology
because my thesis advisor David
kirschner told me that I will face
transitions can be interesting for
cosmology
and one thing after another and then I
found myself doing cosmology but I
remember that when I was a student I
sent to my mother a letter from some
place with saying that yeah cosmology is
so interesting but I am too old to
become a cosmologist
wow there's a those Impressions could
not have been more incorrect Andre and
we're glad that you didn't uh you know
give up on on that at that point but it
is still an exciting field for for young
people but it's also interesting for for
people that are more uh advanced in in
years and I remember yeah I was a
postdoc at Stanford in the late in
actually 1999 2000 I think you were on
sabbatical you and Renata um so we
didn't get a chance to meet back then
but you know even then there were
starting to be really interesting times
for cosmology wmap had been launched and
was about to you know return some of its
First
Data uh and so forth and I don't really
and and I don't really recall when the
impetus was for you to
um or when the idea of chaotic inflation
and and so-called Eternal inflation and
pocket universes I remember reading a
scientific American article by you
um that was uh was really uh
and I wondered you know when when did
you or do you think let me say it like
this do you think of the Multiverse and
inflation as sort of related to each
other there's all sorts of quotes about
you on the internet that if you have
inflation you have the Multiverse
um what is your can you tell the
audience what what is your actual
opinion not just what we might read
about in some article uh
well uh for me it happened in an
interesting way it was actually in ages
when I've learned about the 81 when I
learned about the People by Ellen Booth
it was uh very interesting how it is
possible to use
exponential expansion of the universal
media cosmological problems I studied
this issue a few years earlier but I did
not know what to do about that and I'll
have this idea how to solve many
cosmological problems at once
and then I worked in it and I was so
upset I had ulcer at that time because I
think because I did not see any way to
make it work
and then there was a people by Ellen who
was together as Eric Weinberg saying
that it's impossible to make it to work
then Steve Hawking came to Moscow
proving that it is it cannot be done uh
but I somehow found a way to do it in
new inflation first okay new English uh
I am going to well try to give a lecture
and old inflation is like inflation in a
walking like state which is called
Volkswagen nothing moves a universe
inflates uh new inflation was you
started with the similar initial
conditions but not in the minimum of
potential but maybe on a show or maximum
or show a minimum and after that you
roll for a long time so inflation
happens during Crowley
uh but initially the idea was that you
start with
public bank so that was kind of given to
you that you must start the whole big
bang
and it did not quite work to my own
satisfaction in the USA that you solve
all problems but you actually don't you
start solving them too late after the
big bang already the universe wanted to
collapse it has all chances to collapse
before you start well applying your
tricks
and finally in 83 I found this idea of
chiotic inflation was absolutely good
evening
you just take the potential which looks
like a potential energy of harmonic
oscillator nothing can be simpler than
that right to any peaks in Minima and
and high temperature
and you do not need cosmological phase
transitions which I studied 10 years
before that and I saw that oh I am so
happy that my cosmology of his
transitions are useful for that but no
you're not new cosmological Haze
transitions you just need to have this
quadratic potential and you feel in the
beginning of the universe to stay
somewhere out with minimum that's all
you need so it was so simple
this was for me at the moment after that
I understood that we are not just doing
some magic trick but if harmonic
oscillator can explain you the origin of
the whole universe just a oscillator
being a scale of field whatever so girls
the same mathematics described it okay
so if you just do it and add I say an
equation to this kind of harmonic
oscillator suddenly everything works
then for me it was that is that was the
moment when I understood this is a time
to write a book everything is done
so but this was an 83. all right and and
Eternity emulator
it takes uh from eternity to here
um so you have some slides uh PowerPoint
uh presentation
um would you like to to take over the
screen and share those uh
okay great
maybe maybe my words were some more
definite meaning
okay so shall we start yeah please tell
okay so let's let's do
so this uh I called it Universal
Multiverse you know
because who will have to say whether it
is one or another and what I would like
to do is just explain you the origin of
the question in general but first this
picture uh this picture is became like
standard it was produced in some agency
here in Berkeley maybe okay so it is
right now in journals and textbooks uh
but many years ago there was no this
left part no part where is there in big
bank and inflation everything started
with just with a flash okay and then the
question is was how everything else wait
uh was generated where what is the
origin of the galaxies appearing here
and of course know this in the third
image from the right no long satellite
stuff it was previously impossible but
so let me try to
start with that but before going to
inflation certainly before going to that
I would like to well
give some tribute to uh Albert Einstein
in his uh autobiographical notes which
well like the last thing he wanted to
say to others this is my life this is
what I was doing this is what I think
about everything okay so he diesel years
later
so he said the following
I would like to hear I would read it
because it's so strongly State I would
like to state ethereum which at present
cannot be based upon anything more than
a faith
is okay he had the right to say so okay
the face in the Simplicity
intelligibility of nature there are no
arbitrary constants that's to say nature
so constituted that's a possible
logically to weigh down the strongly
determined slot was that within this
laws only a rationally completely
determined constant occur not constantly
a focused numerical while it could be
changed it without destroying the theory
so this was a dream of a final Theory
and many generations of science this
were looking at sentences like that they
wanted to find literally
and we wanted to find a unique
explanation of everything why for
example electron mass is given by this
why proton mass and neutron was almost
equal to each other so find some
principle explaining that
one of my friends was living in the
apartment number 137 which is of course
in verse of album okay and he thought
that he is blessed so here's the
question why this 137 what is the reason
right and according to this the just
fundamental constant we knew that they
never change we know the electron mass
is everywhere in the universe is the
same so it's just a constantly we need
to understand what why it is 2 000 times
smaller than a proton what is the reason
for that why okay so many things like
that why electron white broadening
neuter why whatever okay so uh the idea
was eventually we'll find the theory
which explained
so what happens now it seems that some
of the concepts may be fundamental
and some of the concepts maybe the
element called them like that
environment
an environmental means well in one part
of the universe you have one value of
for example dark energy
we think that dark energy characterized
by the number like
0.5.7 whatever it is depending on the
experiment oh dark matter is given by
some other number and it must be
everywhere in the same universe
but when we introduce inflation
certainly it's possible to make dark
matter and dark energy in a very
non-dramatic way very trivial way taking
different values in the same universe
but far away from each other
so that's what is a Multiverse many
people take it very dramatically like uh
what is this movie which recently Oscar
oh yeah literary thing everywhere all at
once all people regard Multiverse right
now yeah Andre I often say there's only
one thing bigger than the number of
universes in the Multiverse and it's how
many movies there are about the
Multiverse
yeah you should get some credit do you
get any do you get any royalties uh
Andre when they make no well they did
though uh they invited me for the movie
I just for the premiere of it's moving
in uh San Francisco but unfortunately I
did not have time to go it's a Pity okay
anyway let's go forward
so uh one of the main goals of inflation
in cosmology when it was
proposed was to explain why the universe
is everywhere the same because this is
the question why it is so uniform why it
is so homogeneous
which is one of the questions of Albert
Einstein why everything is like that and
could not be any other way or how he
sometimes uh formulated ways that God
would have any choice okay so this was a
question
and we thought that we are coming very
close to answering it because we
explained what it is uniform why it's
everywhere the same but then when we
study it but then further we were up to
some surprise and that's what we are
going to talk about but first few words
about inflationary cosmology as compared
to standard big back so in standard Big
Bang Theory the idea was first there was
this Bank okay and at the beginning of
the bank of the universal school so if
we consider a box healed for example by
a thousand of protons
excuse me
so if you dig the box and fill it with a
thousands of problems then the universe
expands how many protons inside same
thousand protons okay you start with
something you end with practically the
same the basic idea was that the
Universe expansion is nearly at your
body
if you count all photons right now in
the universe which is about in the part
which we see right now is about 10 to
the degree 90 sorry 88 or something like
that okay so the same amount was
supposed to be in the early Universe
plus minus maybe one order of magnitude
yeah because some uh non-aliabatic
processes happen in the universe but
roughly you get what you started with if
you play moving back you'll see right
now a little bit of temperature and then
you play the movie back and you see
smaller smaller smaller smaller universe
everything dance same 10 to the degree
88 particles in the part of the universe
which we see right now so then you have
a question ha who gave you this 10 to 88
particles at the moment when the
universe was the first time opened its
size okay because how is that there was
nothing and then suddenly they stand to
88 so that's an interesting question can
we do it cheaper like if you hire
somebody to build your house and it
requires this amount of millions of ton
of matter say no but if somebody comes
to you and tells you that I can build
your house from materials which require
you to give me just less than one
milligram of matter I would of the year
a cheater okay
but that's exactly what inflation does
so it can make the universe starting
from less than one milligram of matter
and well I cannot really honestly say
that I am cheating because it actually
follows from the laws of physics which
can be explained though it
so it's extremely extremely weird Okay
so yeah so what was the the questions
which we wanted to answer
what was it before they did that and we
still don't know there are many ideas
right now there are many ideas 40 years
ago as well we started this inflationary
Theory but
um it's probably fair to say that we
still don't know exactly but inflation
allows you to approach this question
differently and propose some answers
which
maybe make sense in context of quantum
cosmology and Quantum responds before
that was well just like abstract science
it was after works by Alex williamkin
Charlie Hawking well my contribution
others uh Quantum cosmology became
relevant to what we study right now
although it still sounds like well
something strange yeah so then we wanted
to explain why the universe is uniform
on that hand white is not exactly
uniform
because if you just postulate the
principle of uniformity they say that
was called cosmological principle by the
way it's in textbooks in many textbooks
they are discussing cosmological
principle even now and they used to make
a joke that some people who do not have
good ideas they sometimes have
principles
until I learned that this principle was
used by Albert Einstein well anyway so
this is a question if you have a
principle that everything it must be
uniform or you are not a man of
principle if you say milk can be a
little bit okay I can take only small
bribes so why it is isotropic
and the simple example uh Galaxy is
ready
around the center of galaxies
irritate about the sun's Stars so
everything contains why Galaxy why the
universe doesn't Okay so
why it is flat
meaning uh parallelized do not intersect
and do not diverge it infinity or at
least in the place where we live we
never seen this happen why it is so
large who gave you this 10 to the 89 or
more particles to build the universe so
all of these questions and many of these
questions can be answered with the help
of inflation well plus some ideas which
we gradually were egging on top of it
later
so the basic ideal inflation data works
not filled with protons instead of that
big heavy vacuum okay uh it sounds that
the cheating starts at this moment
because you vacuum how is that vacuum is
nothing so why working cannot behave
well it's not entirely true this is
actually one of the main problems of
modern physics which is cosmological
constant problem why vacuum is so light
okay why is experimentally density of
energy of working right now is less than
10 to the minus uh 29 gram per cubic
centimeter which is 120 orders of
magnitude smaller than pumpkin density
one of these major problems with
cosmology but in the early Universe well
who knows maybe the vacuum was different
uh when we start studying page
transitions in the early Universe I
found that scale field actually can play
the role of the vacuum and it seemed to
be so simple and so transparent I start
telling about this to others and they
told me no no this cannot be also I've
written a paper about this but when it
was translated into English it was kind
of funny
the name of the article in Russian was
which means is
trying to say that it can take different
values in the early universe
but the translator
translated the title like
is the Lee constant a constant
and the LI is the name of a physicist so
it cannot be any crazier than that in
the people was buried among the papers
which were published but never read
anyway so
um
so suppose you have the this uh
energy of vacuum which can be stored in
classical scale field okay and what a
scale field well example of that here
like a Pioneers on field everybody knows
Hicks field right now everybody knows it
even better but Higgs is an elementary
uh the pilots composite yeah yeah okay
so
um
if this scale field has large energy and
scale field is Lauren scalar which means
that by moving with respect to it I do
not see that anymore because it's it's
inadvariant it's like vacuum because of
that
so it's honest to God vacuum it's
Lawrence and variant quantity and if I
have the box with the Cherry vacuum then
it when the universe expands it Remains
the Same it is vacuum there's nothing
there except for this in a scale of Hill
scale here does not change which means
that energy density of the scale field
does not change
okay if energy density does not change
but the Box expands then the total
energy Inside the Box grows
it is as simple as that when the volume
grows the total energy inside grows
because every normal person said that no
I have studied it in school I know that
it's impossible to create energy from
nothing
so for this person I would say well you
need to take it out into account
expansion of the universe
and when the universe expands it has
actually two types of energies one
energy of matter and another is energy
of space if you wish energy of gravity
and in simple terms so to say the total
energy is exactly equal to zero and they
just rebalance it
you can have total zero which is the sum
of positive energy of matter negative
energy of gravity and if you find the
mechanism how to pump energy from
Gravity to
matter
then that's how the total amount of
total matter
and grows in energy so the energy any
energy of matter in the universe is not
concerned
every cosmologist actually knew it but
they knew it the other way around they
and it's not just a matter of convention
right Andre it's not just a matter of
convention that we it's not just a
matter of convention that we call
positive map you know we call energy
that's positive in associate that with
matter and we call energy that's
negative we associate that with
gravitational potential no it's not the
convention it's uh it's actually a
theorem uh if you study hamiltonian on
the universe of space and time and
matter Etc then it's possible to show
that the total of hamiltonian of the
universe is equal to zero if for example
if you write down the scherting gear
equation or the uh wave function of the
universe you will write it it will look
extremely strange usually a Schrodinger
equation is deep side with DTI whatever
this age multiplied by PSI but you will
see that H is equal to zero and that's
actually uh uh Willard with equation
right so it is something which seemed to
be totally insane but actually it is
it is equation derived in 67 well before
inflation and everything right and it
was called William David equation uh
because wheeler suggested it and David
derived it but really loved it and we
hated it so anyway so this is what is a
result uh but it's just
it's just well a way to tell that we are
not talking about something which we're
just all in thinking on the way to
justify things
slightly differently consider the hot
Universe okay
now this is a big Bank everybody knows
so you know that when the hot Universe
expands then every Photon in the Box
loses its energy because of the red ship
it loses energy by
helping the universe to expand
okay so then the total initial energy of
the big bang when it started is enormous
and then it started depleting okay
so you can lose energy of matter energy
of matter is not conserved it is not the
property of inflation it's in every
cosmology the energy of matter is not
concerned but the find a mechanism of
how it can grow that was a trick
how how
um surprised would you have been if
there if the Higgs boson wasn't found
the Higgs boson is the only uh
Elementary scalar field that physicists
know about the inflaton is another one
if we hadn't found it or maybe you know
the energy that we could come to at the
LHC wasn't sufficient would you have
been worried about inflation in other
words does the hague's discovery give
you more confidence and inflation's
Truth well uh in general there were
always a possibility just like a pie
Mason is a combination of works so Hicks
could be a composite particle as well so
if they found something which they
didn't expect this would not be anything
uh strange and if somebody told me can
you do the inflation without uh well
Elementary scale okay make it from
pheromones but Stravinsky did it easier
he just take gravity and he added an
extra term to gravity uh uh or Einstein
action is R he added the r squared and
the universe starts inflating if this r
squared term is sufficiently large
um
in front of it but after that we do not
need the scalar and now we learned how
to represent this trick
in the form which is equivalent having
gravity plus a scalar so this is
possible to trade sometimes both ways
okay very good
okay so uh uh back to uh well back to
this magic trick so when you take this
box heading like one gram of matter it
expands a little bit and then inside
exponentially large number of well
energy then total energy inside becomes
experimentary large and then if it
decays at the moment of Decay it produce
exponential watch number of photons
protons everything so it's possible to
produce all matter in the universe
practically from nothing
so if this is not a miracle then what is
okay
but that was the idea okay so then uh
formally uh it just will a few equations
just to show that I'm not just dreaming
uh
here is the Hubble constant which is the
scale of the universe is scale shown by
letter a uh the sphere of expansion a
DOT and either divided by is
proportional in this simple
environment for the flat universe it is
proportional to the square of energy
density of the unit oh my God what I did
in this talk for everybody I made the
wrong equation here it is of course not
V squared it's just V oh oh oh can you
erase can it is
yeah anyway shall I stop
no it's fine no okay yeah because
otherwise do we have a lively discussion
okay so your inflation new it's new new
inflation now
no no it's okay okay so the fact is that
this equation it got divided by a is
equal to H
his exponential solution when H is
constant yes
oh well anyway that is what happened and
the total energy of the whole universe
is e to the three h e that's just the
simplest equation of mathematical
physics ever a DOT divided by a is equal
to constant it's exponent okay same
thing which describe you well uh the
Chain Reaction so the chain reaction is
something leading to explain well
explosion of atomic bomb and here you
have explosion of the universe and then
you can produce exponentially a large
amount of matter from nothing okay so
the idea is absolutely brilliant
and the question is of course if
something looks too good to be true then
sometimes it is so one of the questions
is if the universe is totally empty like
vacuum State how do you even know that
it expands exponentially because there
is no markers
there is no way to see there is no
particles there and no one Observer
another Observer moving away from each
other so this becomes a philosophical
question uh what is the meaning of
decision of space in fact it is uh a
debate which was starting from the
Einstein time starting from the theater
the theater invented his exponential
expansion of vacuum in 1917 it is the
same year of great October Revolution in
Russia so I remember the day okay and uh
that is uh was Ill interpreted solution
for many many years in in part because
uh in this
exponential expanding space you can
always find the Cardinal system in which
it expands and you can find the
coordinating system where it first
contracts and then expands and then you
have another coordinate system where you
see yourself surrounded by a black hole
Horizon
so how do you interpret it and if there
is no preferable coordinate system there
is no preferable time also and then
there is no preferable happy surface of
time where this vacuum should decay
and that is why in this scenario Decay
vacuums start being totally chaotic and
what was looking like orderly Universe
very homogeneous very large very uniform
becomes totally non-uniform and
non-homogeneous yes
so that was the point at which Allen
knew it of course and he had written it
in his paper that we have this problem
in the end of the paper so we don't know
how to do it and I read this paper in
the hope that somebody will come with a
solution
so a year later I had my ulcer and no
solution someone in the solution came
and uh well so the solution was one need
to break some rules
in in general uh
inflationary theory is very simple
basics of it it's very very simple as I
say it's a harmonic oscillator or
whatever this simplest equation very Sim
what was difficult about it is some
psychological barriers okay you just
knew that you cannot do something
like even when Alan said this
it's so simple it's exponential then
everybody understood that Jesus must be
false vacuum this must be you must stay
here on the top in the minimum and then
it tunnel down and it only goes directly
to the minimum whatever
and I at that time was running uh well I
studied tunneling okay and I was writing
running some experiments on absolutely
horrible computer in the basement of my
Institute and well I spit on me some
numbers and careful cards whatever and
I've seen that actually tunneling
doesn't go the way it was supposed to go
well sometimes it does and sometimes it
does not sometimes you tunnel directly
to the minimum of the potential and
sometimes you don't know just kneel it
up
and then if you're tunnel near the top
or maybe you do not even need to Tunnel
then when you are sliding down you still
are close to the top
and if you are still close to the top of
the potential energy then you can
inflate during that time okay so the
idea was trivial
uh I got it in summer of 81 and I spent
three or more months getting permissions
for that
and they understood that nobody will
believe me in this So eventually I start
writing two other people simultaneously
explaining all details of that because
there are a lot of details I just said
easy idea but it was nothing easy in
technical details of that so uh in the
end I already got the permission just at
the time when Steve Hogan came to the
conference in Moscow in October
81 and they gave a talk at the
conference and everyone there suggested
me that they will smuggle with people
abroad but at that time I already just
got a permission so no need to smuggling
right and then next day after my total
conference Hawking gave a talk the
Sternberg Institute uh
Moscow University and I happened to be
there and somebody asked me to translate
so I translated his talk or for an hour
uh and he was not quite ready to talk so
usually he would give his student do the
talking and he would correct him with
some but at that time Hawking will say
one word and students and they were
discussing all the inflation and I was
supposed to translate this one word so
it did not make much sense so I started
giving a talk give say one word students
say one word and I say I still wanted to
say this so we continue
it was fine he was proving that it's
impossible to improve all the inflation
and at some moment he started talking
something more lengthy and he said but
uh recently Andrea Linde came with a
possibility to solve this problem and
the heavily translated
and then he continued but his sister is
completely wrong
I was translating for everyone why my
theory is wrong and then I finished and
they said that I translated by I
disagree and explained why and then I
asked him do you want to discuss it he
says sure and well so we became friends
so that was very interesting and after
that with this whole
Symposium in Cambridge a few years later
I was invited and my miracle was able to
come so that's how it was anyway so this
breaking the rules uh first breaking was
you are not
tunneling down to the minimum but you
just hang around near the maximum for a
while and then slowly moved on
so the idea was good but then when
people started studying what happened on
the way etc etc uh this muscle Symposium
it was found that in this scenario
perturbations of density produced uh
during inflation they in the simplest
versions of this scenario they are too
large
in scenario died so he is a scenario
leave for one year and died pretty
quickly
by the way a few months after I
suggested the scenario it was also uh
essentially the same scenario was
proposed by Stanford and Albert here in
the United States anyway uh this
scenario died and it was understood
morally as clearly there was some hope
maybe when we were flying away from this
nuffield Symposium in summer 82 but uh
well there was always hope that we will
resurrected somehow difficult to bring
all these things together and then
eventually I invented this security
inflation scenario and it was so much
simpler that basically it provides the
well frame work for a large variety of
other inflation scenarios but at the
beginning not everybody wanted to
believe Steve Hawking instantly believed
and that was the only scenario here way
to follow it was his own verifications
so the idea is that you just take scale
with you you don't need the maximum you
don't need a major stable
false vacuum minimum whatever you don't
use high temperature you don't need
anything you do not need hot Universe
okay you have just a speck of space
it can be as small as plunken size it
cannot be any smoke or any smaller than
that and if there it has a sufficiently
homogeneous scale of field in it so then
the scale field wants to go down
but
equation one of this equation is oops
okay one of these equations uh for the
scale of field rolling in the universe
contains a special term which looks like
a friction term in the equation of
motion for harmonic oscillator three H5
dot that's a very strange term but
that's not something which we invented
it's just well you study scale field in
the current space your rate equation you
find this term so this term freezes this
scale of field when it rolls down
so even though it is sliding down along
potential then it slides down extremely
slowly and because it slide down
extremely slowly it works as if it will
vacuum State F if as if its energy was
just a potential energy practically no
kinetic and then in this case the same
magic trick the same equations which
were previously applied for the vacuum
worked for this as well and you have uh
inflation but then when scalar field
became smaller expansion of the unit
becomes slower trouble constant becomes
smaller prediction term becomes smaller
and scale he'll start oscillating that's
all okay so you start with the field
hanging on the wall sticking to the wall
sliding slowly slowly slowly and when it
is near minimal start oscillating when I
start oscillating the process by which
the scale field produces particles
decays into these particles and you have
put big bank after that
so that's that's it you need the
harmonic oscillator and the lucky scale
field uh which was Will unruly uh
changing at some uh height to start with
so for me at that moment uh these the
question is where the inflation is some
species something specifically invented
whatever when you have it in the theory
of harmonic oscillator that's something
way uh more than I expected
I've always wanted to ask you is when
you have reheating typically if you're
looking at it as a friction term the in
in saying molecular statistical
mechanics the energy of friction is
generated by matter right so here it's
the friction is occurring in a in a our
abstract space and it's because of the
hobble expansion yeah if you just keep
this this equation nothing is skill
field just loses energy uh and uh
all energy what you need you need to add
some terms describing expand well
interaction of the scale here with
something else yes so then what happens
is very interesting you have this
harmonic oscillator scale of field and
it interacts with other
Fields staying there in the vacuum like
with their particles they are not yet
present there in the vacuum but then the
scale of you changes masses all these
oscillators in vacuum
and this is non-ideobatic process
so when you change the mass all the time
then you excite these perturbations out
of the vacuum State and the universally
hits
uh there are alternative mechanisms that
you can also you can just well just
simply by installating you will
calculate some diagrams and you see that
the diagrams have imaginary part so you
really need to work yeah so reheating
doesn't come for free it is not just all
these equations you need to have point
of view theory on top of it
okay so let's move forward so you start
with say Plank and mass 10 to the minus
5 gram okay then this Plankton Mass
Dental magnified gram it has a size 10
to the minus 33 centimeter
it's nothing okay all right uh and uh as
later Yankees well actually his idea
came a year before but in a different
context you can create the universe from
nothing
just why I study this way function of
the universe maybe something happens and
then uh we uh well whatever this is a
separate story so let's just start with
this blanket the mean and it may be very
in homogeneous to start with but what
happens is inflation makes it
homogeneous okay it may start with large
kinetic energy but inflation sucks away
this large kinetic energy so if in the
beginning potential energy dominated
then you have inflation beginning in
that case Okay this was a very easy idea
uh in gr nothing is very easy so the
really uh detailed
calculations which resulted two exactly
to the same answer which I just told you
were completed just a year ago
but before that there was many other
calculations but essentially that's
that's the idiot so if you make the
universe not extremely inhomogeneous and
not extremely large kinetic energy then
sooner or later it becomes inflationary
and that's the solution of the problem
of initial conditions in this context
but I but again just to be clear for for
people that aren't experts in this this
does presuppose and and you could make
the mass smaller than the plank Mass
there's nothing magical about the plank
Mass but it's a very high density you
know per cubic centimeter if you
calculate divide by 10 minus three three
thirty three but
um but it does presuppose that there is
an existence of a scalar field and
people will ask the question where does
that come from just as the last word
does God come from so how do you think
about it how do you think about where
does that scalar field come from well
it's always Eternal yeah just like one
of the examples is the Higgs field where
this Higgs field came from uh our nature
is complicated there are some uh fields
which are like pheromones okay
from oh okay sorry that's electron how
you live without electron that's so easy
it's a direct equation uh well dear
equation so complicated okay let us do
something simpler we have Vector Fields
like field it's simply it does not have
all of these complexities with
anti-commuting variables Etc so you
understand what the vector field is here
okay so the scale of field is something
like electrostatic potential yeah
it's a little bit dishonest what I just
said because electrostatic potential is
the Zero's component of a vector okay
but uh if for example if you are
surrounded by uh
electric field with a constant potential
110 volt you never see it's like another
vacuum state
okay so if you have uh 110 volts in
years and you have 220 in Russia don't
touch them by two of your hands okay
because you'll be dead yeah but if you
are everywhere 110 you do not even know
that it is anything you need to have
zero yeah I remember the first time I
heard you speak about this Andre uh you
talked about a bird and you said the
bird is standing on a wire and uh it's
okay as long as the bird doesn't put its
uh its foot on the ground and the other
foot on the wire uh it'll become a
cooked uh how do you say potato
it becomes fired it says Birds
evolutionary disappear that's a phoenix
right yeah okay good thank you well so
the the point is that you start with
pretty soon theoretically ideologically
yes civil construction whether this
simple can be really realized in nature
that's a question where the inflation
happened with a simple scale potential
which is quadratic the answer is no
okay and this answer is a result of
experimental uh we will studies of
inflation and cosmology the scale field
with the potential M squared y squared
would produce your uh the spectrum of L
but I did not tell what spectrum anyway
going forward this theory was several
years ago ruled out but instead of that
with some magic transformation you can
save it and make it completely
consistent with all presently available
data that will follow up but right now
this was a nice model to look at to
explain the simple idea behind inflation
okay so the idea is then that all matter
in the universe was born after the GK of
the scale of you during inflation
and there's something else when we
create this Red Bull
because of this expansion all
inhomogeneities which surrounded the
ball were stretched away like think
about Everest here okay let's stretch it
horizontally one thousand times it
becomes a plateau so that's what
inflation does with all previous
existing in homogeneities the ball
becomes totally homogeneous it surface
becomes flat it's just like
the Earth is flat
unless you can travel around it but
traveling around the universe of this
size is kind of complicated definitely
okay so uh
the universe becomes flat that's one of
the predictions of inflationary
cosmology okay uh
let's see what happens later but one
then the question is where the galaxies
came from
yes and the answer was that if we just
stretch and don't do anything else then
sorry these theories are already ruled
out because we see galaxies but we were
lucky to have some people who are
sitting in the office nearby whatever
studying one of activations in the early
universe and what happens in this
you have wonderful Creations even right
now in this room
they appear disappear appear disappear
you do not care about them on the time
scale which we have you just see nothing
you say this is a property of our vacuum
some point of operations
but during inflation well the whole
inflation was lasting 10 to the minus 36
seconds so small things was not a
concern for inflation it was actually
pretty pretty interesting so you have
some fluctuations jumping from the
vacuum but in inflation within a very
short time stretched it okay you have
wave and it stretched it and when the
wavelengths of reservation becomes large
then if you write down the full equation
for the stable field it contains some
gradient terms it can take kinetic terms
and kinetic term leads to the freezing
of the scale of field
because of the Hubble constant this
three Hy doctor yes if scale if you
tries to move fast
it tries to stop moving fast so when the
oscillations are very very fast then
it's very hard to stop them but when the
universe expands and the wavelengths
become
large then this dominant term in the
equation for the scale field becomes
this three h y Dot and the scale of
field freezes so you have these
wonderful equations and at some moment
is stop oscillating it freezes
then on the top of it another one
breezes
and on the top of it another foundation
for reasons and you have this mountain
one oscillation of over another over
another
um this resembles me something which
I've uh read as a child uh there was
this uh stories of Baron minhausen I
don't know where the kids here learned
they don't know there was a famous liar
Maron in house and he wants uh will
travel to Siberia when it was extremely
cold and she said that well it was so
cold I was trying to call for my friends
uh and I I tried to well produce some
songs
but the sound did not go away because it
was so cold that the sound was frozen
inside
and then I well made a cave for me and
slow and I was sleeping there but in the
morning sun appeared again and then
suddenly I hear the sound
this is the sound of my horn was
defrosted
well so that happens in inflation what
was their Frozen sound it was defrosted
and it was the origin of the structure
in the universe this inhomogeneities
which were produced uh they produce it
because they were in homogeneous of
density when they have a large field you
have larger energy density at this place
you have galaxies so you have a
mechanism of production of galaxies in
the universe I I super simplify the
mechanism in fact okay super super
simplified but that was a mechanism and
when this
two men who were sitting in the office
nearby they studied for patients in this
Caribbean skin model in fact okay and
they told me that we know how to produce
galaxies from nothing and I told them
okay guys be serious
Quantum fluctuations okay how can you
produce wonderful Creations from nothing
and uh they explained me
and then I remember that this is related
probably to something abstract like this
maybe quantum gravity Corrections are
square terms arabinsky model and then I
learned actually that this is actually
what happens with any scale of field in
the universe and once you understand
that you understand something very very
important
that galaxies can be created from one of
operations that's insane you know
no it is and Andre you know one we're
not going to talk
um about alternatives to inflation very
much if at all but one thing I've
pointed out is that all other models
whether it's the conformal cyclic model
yes whether it's the bouncing mode they
all have scalar Fields so what you just
said holds for all the Rival theories
including including those of uh of uh
sir Roger Penrose and Paul steinhardt
and Aegis and Neil so nobody can now I
would find it very interesting if there
was a model of early universe
cosmogenesis that doesn't have a scalar
field that would be wonderful uh if only
for the for the variety of ideas not for
you know comparing so anyway I I think
what you just said is applicable just
from my listeners many of whom are
cosmology this was going to appear in
one of the slides of my dog oh wow
people who say that well Multiverse is
your problem no Multiverse is a problem
of everyone who uses similar mechanism
okay we'll return to that but not a
problem but an advantage okay yes a
generic feature a generic a generic
feature yes good neutral
okay so um
um talking about the consequences of
that and how do we really know uh where
the inflation the idea is Right many
years later
because well uh
many people say okay well inflation just
does its work but maybe you can can you
prove it there are so many different
models of inflation uh can you
distribute for all of them can you just
move the idea okay so let me tell you
something I'm not going to stay at each
point because there are 10 different
points here they discussed okay I will
just briefly mention some of them the
universe is flat let me Google one this
is a prediction of this model okay so uh
it is experimentally shown to be almost
flat with accuracy about one percent
now I would say this is a victory this
is what inflation does it predicts and
that's what we found
but on the other hand uh there was a
time in the theory of inflationary
cosmology in the middle of 90s when the
general consensus of cosmologists was
that Omega is nautical one which means
the universe is what but Omega is equal
approximately 0.3 because old known Dark
Matter together contributed only to
point three and then what was our
integration at that time this was a
near-death experience okay it just will
to those people who ask is it possible
to disprove the whole idea of the
universe just like that okay so uh we
had this new death experience at that
time and uh several people start
proposing models of Omega non-equal 2 to
1 in inflation cosmology and I also
contributed to that
and then what happens uh gradually we
found that these models are extremely
ugly most of them simply do not work the
first model was proposed by Neil Turk
and others and in the representation it
just did not work okay
I will not describe to all the reasons
there are some models remaining working
uh you know one of them works completely
ugly and they're telling you honestly
because it was my own model it was
extremely ugly but it worked in
principle but it was extremely ugly so
in principle it is possible to do uh
Omega non equal to one you make the
radius of curvature large as you want it
could be open or closed right I mean
there is data from melchiori or from
Planck that melchiori and others and
Kami and Kowski have claimed our you
know three sigma inconsistent with
flatness but they require a radius of
curvature of 80 gigaparsec so yeah at
that level how how is it really the side
yeah
yeah one way another I'm just saying the
holy that being very very inventive you
can avoid the prediction okay so you
can't have models which makes the
universe slightly open or slightly
closed I'm just saying that it's
extremely difficult okay so those people
who will say oh such a beautiful model
at some moment they will say oh my God
this is not as beautiful I wanted it
okay so this is a real life you want to
have a beauty but you have what you have
okay no uh it is right now at least
close to the beauty
at the moment the observable part of the
universe is uniform
it is kind of uniform but it's exactly
as non-uniform as it should be and if
you say but was it a prediction because
it was okay yeah that's this
cosmological principle that it must be
uniform but nobody knew how uniform it
actually is uh people expected to have a
duration of
homogeneity at the level 10 to the minus
three
excuse me let me drink some water
so I remember how
in the very beginning of 80s because
novikov who was a famous collaborator of
uh
he didn't say that well you know
inflation in the universe is ruled out
because it must produce quantum's
locations uh the level of 10 to the
minus 3 to describe or whatever and we
studied this 10 to the minus 3
experimentally and we found nothing so
no this Theory cannot work and then Dark
Matter was discovered later and with
account taken of dark matter and all
other stuff we are living right now
example to the perturbation which is
like an order of magnitude smaller but
this was for some of us and near-death
experience when we knew that this theory
predicts something which is already
ruled out
uh it is isotropic and in particular
let's say it does not rotate well okay
you see it doesn't repeat but we did not
know that it does not receive with this
degree of accuracy right the prediction
was that it doesn't but with these
degrees of accuracy you is required to
have plant cellulite to uh study it
that's right even the first model for
polarization uh was by Lord Martin Reese
who was one of the many guests on the
podcast and his model was that the
Universe to generate polarization how to
expand anisotropically with the
quadripolar Distortion and he was right
that the universe is polarized CMB is
polarized but for the wrong reason so
that could have rolled out in play at a
at a very early stage but it didn't
right yeah
well uh so uh perturbations produced by
inflation are ideal body it could be
that the uh as a curator uh some people
whom I I know well in well my own
liberty physical Institute they were
talking about a relational like vertex
perturbation whatever so lots of
different models survived adiabatic and
the adiabatic is what inflation always
produce and as a courage it can
uh it cannot produce Vector perturbation
so far all models of inflation uh
produce a scalable perturbations or
tensor peripovations which cannot
produce vectors so if there is a
question hunt for inflation let's kill
it let's find Vector perturbations well
it will probably kill either the whole
Theory
or the theory not including cosmic
strings which if you add the paper
inflation a little bit by cosmic strings
they will produce you different types of
perturbations including reactors if you
want okay so it's possible to avoid the
problems but it is extremely difficult
to avoid them if these problems arise so
is it possible to disprove inflation
that was one of the questions which
always asks the answer is yeah it's
possible at least to make life of people
who will discuss it extremely
uncomfortable
unlike preservations produced by cosmic
strings okay so in the beginning I
remember how well Robert brandenburger
who was writing more reviews on the
situation at that time his review was
always divided into two pieces cosmic
strings and uh inflation like a small
watching the more or less were on the
same uh when he was trying to prove that
if they can be right of course he never
mentioned for whatever reason the cosmic
strings do not solve the homogeneity and
isotherapy and other problems they at
best can produce your
structure in the universe and then later
we found that it does not do the
structure properly
experimentally because they are not
responsible for so many peaks in the
Spectrum which appear in inflation
respect but again this was
that experience do you find the Peaks or
you do not find the Peaks
the large this is very delicate thing
because of some stage we knew okay the
Peaks are there whatever but is it
possible just to
do something like not to do philosophy
but to do something with the universe so
that uh concerning this adiabatic
perturbation that everything would be
fine and still nevertheless inflation
cannot do that okay uh who could it be
possible and the answer came after W map
in plant they have shown uh
anti-correlation between uh temperature
perturbations and uh
these
modes of
polarization so when this thing appeared
some other models were passed away
okay so now one not exactly flat and
what means flat flat means you take one
skill and then you take a scale ten
times bigger and then you take a time
scale that they're bigger perturbations
on each of these logarithmically scaled
scale to exponential scale scale must be
approximately the same that was specific
thing that inflation does because if
this is slow rule whatever the amplitude
on this exponential scale scaling 10
times and 10 times approximately should
be the same that was a prediction okay
prediction of 81 this is aldovic
no that is the thing yes
he did not predict it he wanted to be
flat this is the elevation Horizon okay
and so what people who did inflation if
they wanted to do of course he wanted to
reproduce you
they obtained disappointing result they
produce Spectrum which was slightly not
flat and then wise people they published
it and saying that what we predict is
similar to hildewish but it is not flat
this was their second prediction that it
is flat but logarithmically different
from this and that was the second
prediction a prediction could be right
and could be wrong so it seems right now
that it is right
well
several other things here I will we
should just say Andre why is it deviate
from one flatness because inflation ends
right it is inflation yes exactly
exactly because uh the field initially
was large our constant was large the
steel field was moving slowly then it
stopped moving faster then it stopped
moving faster the inflation ends okay so
on the way to that things change
were constant
oh no I should not go there because if
it were constant then in fact we are
back to all the inflation where Delta
row row is all the other one so right
yeah so now uh let's go to the point 10.
that was yet another near the experience
which did not happen Okay uh somewhere
in 2012 or 13
oh my God I am already talking for now
it's okay don't worry don't worry no
yeah pull more than enough okay so in uh
uh maybe this is episode one yes
I have plenty of I have plenty of
storage on my computer so don't worry uh
yeah but
my local Court yeah if you if you want
to stop after you know a little bit we
could stop sure okay
uh 12.
there were some rumors that
non-gaussianity is going to be reported
by wmap based on the recent results
I ask people from Double Image they say
we don't know anything who told you
about that like but nevertheless
everywhere very very worried and very
interested because you know everything
is already known about inflation uh but
if we can produce non-gociology then
there are so many different versions of
inflation so all postdocs were
enthusiastic because they have so much
work for them already if none gaussiani
and also because even if special type
will be found then all I mean all single
field inflation and models will be ruled
up that would be such a statement
of course you'll say okay let's add
other fields and it's possible to do so
so people will study different models
producing large negotionality it is it
was possible the models were ugly but
there are many of them so
um well and then suddenly there was
announcement from Planck at that time I
was in Europe I was boarding the
airplane
returning to uh Stanford and uh Ronaldo
coach my wife sent me a message that
people from
Blanca were making an announcement right
now and I am a boarding airplane
and she texted me one one word only no
non-gaussianity okay so everything and
you had written a paper with her super
curvaton well you guys were looking for
large curves it was with well but but in
terms of super gravity sorry yeah
yeah okay uh and uh honestly
uh well uh it's it's a different story
what I'm trying to say that it was like
that uh it was possible that they find a
very significant long ocean it's still
possible okay and that is why a
cosmological experiments are so
significant because if you find some
specific types of non-govicianity even
at very low level it will rule out
enormous amount of different models and
we will need to reconsider what we
consider nice and not nice whatever this
just answers the question whether we're
talking about experimental science or
whether talking about metaphysical
developments right or making people
happy because they have something simple
explaining stuff well as you see here is
these 10 points
it's very much physical science which
can be maybe it is difficult to rule it
out the whole thing
but
every particular model can be tested and
rolled out in fact this is what this
plan satellite was about we studied
different models so they produce these
marvelous images all across the sky and
they ruled out quite a lot of models
they produced these images which each
point is in fact should be considered a
separate experiment for different
wavelengthses they found the amplitude
and whatever they produce ways on the
curve which is uh well the curve which
corresponds to some relatively simple
inflationary model
and then other experiment came in the
very recent ones and they are finding
more and more Peaks here so we're
learning quite a lot and then it is
possible to uh continue this way
so this is very experimental science and
is it possible to test it even better
but of course you know better than many
okay it is possible to study
gravitational waves as well
gravitational waste produced by
inflation would be a magic source of
information
they sometimes are sold like uh
um what is called Smoking Gun for
inflation I think that this is a bit
dishonest salesman pitch
inflation already has enough uh well the
evidence in its favor and Smoking Gun is
the criminalistic uh pool of 19th
century so we have many other tools in
our disposal
so if we find the modes of gravitation
waves it will be fantastic not only for
inflation like one a very significant
evidence in favor of inflation but also
by for quantum gravity and Quantum
cosmology in general and also because
they would bring us information about
interactions at energies like Many Many
Wonders of magnitude greater than what
can be obtained at LHC and other
accelerators on the earth so this would
be Majestic and therefore it worse all
the money spent on them
this is more or less summary of what we
had at least in
2018 after the Planck
ET with all of this data and NS not
exactly equal to one but close to one
exactly as in conference who wanted them
to be in this FNL local is not greater
than one as we were afraid but it's
smaller than one plus minus a very large
error which will be removed gradually
with experiments and this picture shows
just an illustration how far people went
so this pinky oval is what was what was
it seven year one wmap results so these
ellipsets were huge and we did not know
what is there and what is not there and
there were so many models which would
satisfy all experimental data these two
yellow
blobs upstairs this was standard M
squared for squared model it was
perfectly good in this situation okay
this oops let me go back the
okay so these area here slightly to the
left and down is something which is
called natural inflation was working
good if you
um if you instead of M squared for
square do something else there are some
series of other models which are
possible and that is the latest okay
that is a blank to a 2018 plus bicep
kick so well uh
and this yellow blue ellipses is what
appears if you take into account the
data by uh bicep okay buy supplies plan
together so y-square model is parallel
by model is out potential fight whatever
any potential with any degree 5 to the
end Phi to the Alpha Phi to the beta
they're all ruled out by this set of
events so if you say is it possible to
roll out many models yes where is
natural inflation it is out totally it
was sold as a natural inflation such a
natural thing whatever it was one of the
main candidates for a ruling model of
inflation it is out of this counter okay
so we need to do something about this
and now what is this this is yellow line
and red line and what are these green
ellipses in the very very bottom of it
well so this one in the at the bottom is
inflation model these two points
entities model 20 years ago yeah and it
still fits experimental data well maybe
it may be not exactly fit maybe it's
like one Sigma out whatever a data by
themselves are not as precise as we want
in his inflation also feed the data and
yellow and red line they start at Phi
squared model and they go down all the
way and these are alpha traptors and
this Alpha tractors is a set of models
which uh Renato colors I and some of our
collaborators invented so the idea is
this is
our collaborator Rose yeah you take the
original model which were written with M
squared by square and here one
modification only you change kinetic
terms there
in them you may even change M Square to
a square term
whatever you do if you go to canonical
variables after that you get go back to
um uh normal canonical term but
potential becomes a function of
hyperbolic Tung
and this potential
has always a form which is a plateau
in these models this provide perfect fit
to all of the data by
bicep and Planck and what is interesting
they provide a good fit even if I start
not with M Square 5 square but with
Lambda 5 to the force but with Y to the
degree two thirds whatever is it is it
important to know what the potential is
or that it exists you know it start
being less important what potential is
it started being more important what
kinetic term is
reminiscent Andre so nowadays people are
talking well we measure the Higgs mass
and now the LHC is almost done I mean
hopefully it's not done and it can do a
lot of good science but but now the
priority shift to now we have to map out
the Higgs potential
um do you agree that that's a good use
of of um of of the of the field in other
words
equivalently it seemed like you don't
care what the potential is in inflation
so you only care that it exists so is
there is there a disconnect are people
really spending their energy the right
way
well it's hard for me to say and fulfill
oh my my energy colleagues what they
should do and what they shouldn't uh the
whole storyboard which is very
interesting but you know because they
started with a standard model and
standard model was so insanely
successful
these all on a very very simple
principles right they link them now
change your principle please one of the
principles was it a normalizability of
the theory right because in the context
quantum gravity seemed to be very far
away and so they are doing best if you
take a potential which is quadratic it's
a normalizable you have word it's a
normalizable if you have it at 5 to the
degree six
sorry you have a problem okay so uh it
is possible to modify the theory but you
do this Magnificat modification of every
anything of kinetic terms of every you
uh break the premise of the original
model so you should be very very careful
at each of your steps because then if
you make the theory non-renormalizable
and all of your second third fifth Loop
calculation are based on the use of your
normalizability well you better watch
your step right okay so
in this model what we found is that many
of the results under certain conditions
many of the results do not depend on the
potential and the origin of the singular
term is actually Azure geometry it is a
hyperbolic space if you do Azure you do
models which are well so far cheating or
experimental data I don't know what will
happen eight ten years later because now
we are trying to feed the data
satisfying both
CMB people and Supernova people and
there are some tendency of people who
try to satisfy both to say that actually
if we do it your NS tends to be greater
so we have models which we can which
which can do this as well okay right now
what I discussed so far is just a simple
model it's really simple you just talk M
Square to a squared modify kinetic term
you're done you have everything covered
and you can
you can dial any value of the uh tensor
index so you can uh if if you find right
now on bicep if you find graduation
waves it will tell you what the alpha is
um there is however some discrete
spectrum of preferable outfits which
kind of follow from string theory and
extended supergrity and that is a work
for another college and Sergio Ferrara
and one of them is specific which you
maybe already found whatever so that's a
very interesting field to be discussing
but guess what I am already more than an
hour well an hour and a half I don't
know what we are going to do maybe I
will just tell you how to solve the
problem of initial conditions yeah that
is that is very interesting yes please
continue yeah so let's take
this model with this non-minimal kinetic
term here okay so the potential in this
direction is shown here as a function of
the field fight so it is hyperbolic
touch it is lengthy lengthy lengthy you
and it gives great agreement with
experimental data and this second
potential is just one of my simplest
quadratic potential
okay so when uh uh uh
Planck produces the results there was
well some people and we know who they
said they actually plant these proves uh
inflationary Theory because the Planck
is favoring the models with a long plot
in them but these models have problems
with initial conditions okay so here is
the model which has both of them present
in the same potential one is quadratic
and another is with SWAT potential and
that's how inflation happens there your
third is at as high energy density as
possible because then it is my standard
M squared y squared Theory which is it
will be M squared Sigma squared Theory
okay and you go up to the plant density
you can easily produce a blanken size
domain and this plugin size the mean you
can solve problem which initial
conditions and you have inflation but
then this inflation is going to end so
this bow rolls down from the Planck
intensity and fall into the plateau but
while it is rolling the fuel Phi does
not change because the friction term is
huge in the horizontal Direction and
potential in the horizontal direction is
flat exponentially flat so this field
Phi does not move while field Sigma
solves the problem of initial conditions
okay so there's a two field yes after
after it stopped rolling down to its
minimum then the ball which is now
driven by the field Phi start falling to
this minimum of the potential and the
theory is described by Alpha adapters
and Alpha attractors fit all the data so
you solve the problem of initial
conditions and you will explain the
presently available experimental data in
one setting it wasn't my paper which was
well my lizous
lectures in
and then the same people who claim that
uh all you have this problem they
apparently never looked at that because
this model was known to them and they
said that this problem is unsolvable
that we have some data disproving
inflation and models so it was not quite
professional I would say anyway
some latest development on that it was
in the People by Poorman in East they
studied numerically
models of this type
starting from whatever density and
all of this field evolving they just
confirmed the expectations which we had
at that time so I think that these
questions should be just finished
discussing but this is the last one in
this series just how it fits to the
latest uh bison data so I imagine that
there are some discrete instead of
values of alpha which would
create experimental data but also
go from the uh being motivated from
extended super gravity models and there
is a discrete set of them the alpha is
equal to one third two thirds
three-thirds uh four-thirds five-thirds
sixth seventh okay
okay that's just it okay seven Norms
whatever seven something and then the
upper one gives predictions show by this
uh almost flat line here depending on uh
how many Holdings you have and it
crosses exactly in half these blue
ellipse which is a preferable uh results
by uh latest by of course it may be
considered just like a joke because
bicep does not climb discovery of any R
yes yes because the sigma the accuracy
is comparable with the size of this dark
blue region nevertheless it's kind of
fun to see that some of the models which
are the best models uh we were able to
come from come with
uh they are already at the area which
can be tested confirmed or ruled out
just slightly pushing forward right
slightly who knows bicep gets said that
we hope to improve accuracy is three
times to reach Sigma uh three thousands
within five years if the unify and unify
their forces with other people who do uh
well more accurate a beautiful lacing
for graduation so one way or another I'm
not stealing anybody's work here no I'm
just saying that it's interesting that
what previously considered to be uh
impossible that you need to reach insane
accuracy to come close to test something
like Stravinsky model you must go there
uh well seven times no approximately two
and two slightly uh strabinsky model
corresponds to Alpha equal one
and this one does it also correspond to
r0 like the green ellipse is this are
they at zero
yeah you see on the graph like that it's
very difficult to point the ellipse in
the proper place right so originally in
all of these blank models they just puts
dragon skin model and he in his
inflation model to the bottom well if
you take a magnifying glass and look at
the plotting not zero see actually they
were slightly off okay so they predict
are approximately 0.004
it's hard to distinguish it on this plot
but it's not actually zero right so my
my question you know I think what we'll
do is maybe we'll do a part two someday
uh an episode two with in person uh I
will come up and visit you or you come
here for a colloquium uh you have a
standing invitation
um but uh and there's a lot of questions
from the audience and from uh professors
like will Kinney and and Aegis and
others well we'll talk about those
another time but my question is is
really pertinent to as an
experimentalist uh it's very hard to
know when to stop you know because you
can always add on a decimal place you
can always do is there a natural place
to stop looking for proof quote unquote
of inflation that there is an actual
floor
um of tensor to scalar ratio that's in
other words it has to be there's a lower
limit and it's about 10 to the minus six
um in a touch of scalar and that's
because the primary the the CMB scaler I
mean the scalar perturbations
we'll have uh they'll generate tensor
particular gravitational Waves by virtue
of their first derivative they'll start
they'll start you know it'll be a second
order uh scalar perturbations will
generate first order tensor
perturbations because you have mat you
know curvature in motion effectively
it's very small and it's probably out of
the reach of of anybody's lifetime to
measure to R equals 10 minus six but is
there a goal I mean that would also be
very interesting because if you didn't
see secondary anisotropy of of uh B
modes at that level that would mean that
Einstein is wrong not just you know uh
Guth and Linda so anyway is there
guidance for me and my colleagues as
experimentalists when would you say
Brian enough stop it's it's enough money
it's enough time is there a reason or
should you always keep looking keep
adding the next decimal place
well I will tell you uh starting with
some analogy and and that's what happens
when LSC was trying to find a super
symmetric particle whatever okay
which was not a very pleasant story okay
they wanted a kind of almost not really
promised but they expected to find it
okay yeah uh and now they are using this
machine further and further and further
and the question is does it make sense
to build a new machine
because it's going to be extremely
expensive
and uh what is guaranteed that you find
anything because we just bill expected
uh super symmetry to be broken at a very
low scale in my opinion the argument was
full okay but that was a war okay this
law suggested people to look in this
direction
um well so they didn't find uh is there
anything special that they are going to
find there
so I have heard one argument with a
person who explained why they need to do
it
and when I have heard it
she said and we need to continue doing
it because we didn't find anything
I say what
okay uh that's interesting
and the next step was in anyway Chinese
will be
oh well whatever no uh
I remember how people from Planck at
this first conference in 2013
they asked me some
people who were the head of responses we
need to
have some goal for the future and would
you suggest us
uh maybe there are some goal like study
further because we did not find uh
cancer perturbations at the level which
we studied is there any reason to go
further
I said
well you want a polite want to answer
whatever you want and it was
obviously everybody need to have a goal
in them to apply for ground whatever and
I say honestly
we do not have any Target
well there is a target there are two
Targets uh starabinski and Hicks
would you spend like a how many billion
dollars which you do not have yet
just having two Targets
and I'm not sure that anybody give you
this money
uh I don't know this is a reality of
course if you talk with this String
Theory people I said at that time they
just issued a report listing
lots of different String Theory models
with the targets which they have and
their targets is horrible 10 to the
minus 6 or 10 to the minus seven I would
not advise you to apply program to study
this
so I don't know what to do
half a year later I met had written in
Berkeley and we just exchanged some
opinions and I told him about the story
and he told me I would definitely uh
advise them to continue search because
it is so fundamentally important
then we were trying to find out whether
we have any other targets between among
the in addition to Stravinsky and Hicks
and uh
we found we found that we were going to
a conference in uh oh my God
and that means
getting old now it's been two hours
hundreds yeah right anyway the the the
the point was that
we just stopped at some burger place
on the way I don't remember the
ways but it was strongly recommended to
us and because it was strongly
recommended to us the lion was extremely
long and we sat down and doing nothing
we start using napkins me and my wife
are not a coach trying to figure out
what else can be like similar to and
actually what can we do something
interesting and uh
we had something strange
on the way of the second Burger will
already have it formulated when we
arrived to the conference we already
have a theory next day because I was
calculating at night and this was the
first example of this Alpha tractors wow
except for it was for Alpha equal one we
saw that it's not not possible but it
gives the same predictions or
extravinsky and chics and it was totally
diff absolutely different model okay but
it gave the same prediction now after
that there was this Alpha attractors and
what they found that related predictions
are very stable to the choice of the
potential and depend only on this offer
which is geometry
and then I looked at erinato looking
some
websites uh studying
air Azure a little during that what are
they doing
let's continue working and they say
don't
and I know that you know
she has a company of mathematical
intuition which beats me always I don't
know how it works but it Clicks in a
different way and so I started after her
studying this we have written a paper
called Azure in the sky
explaining how all these things fit
together so you have not only a
model built for the purpose of doing
something interesting it was some there
was some beauty in it and we continue
this research for like 10 years since
and still interesting stuff appears here
but then we found these extra targets so
the question is whether there will be
some
well-motivated targets and then until
they appear
but right now we have the wild west with
h0 and stuff so this may uh will change
our expectations quite considerably this
is the last follow-up on the alpha
attractors are you are you suggesting
that there may be a new observable you
know like Ada and um Epsilon are for you
know the ordinary inflationary uh
relations between consistency
relationships between NS and R could
there be an observable potentially some
in some space Maybe FNL or something
that connects Sigma and Phi you know
could there be some properties of the
alpha tractor potential that are
translated into experimental observables
for people like me this Alpha is related
to the curvature of the hyperbolic space
so by measuring Alpha you're finding
geometry not of our universe but all
these
space which is of the space where skill
field lives yeah okay so uh
that's Renata I would be unable to say
anything as well I want to get her on
the podcast too so if you can introduce
me to her that would be great okay
um so Andre just two more questions
um one uh well they're both from Alan
well two are from Alan Lightman uh I I
promised him I would ask uh you the
questions that he asked me to ask you
because you asked me to ask him a
question and he obliged and gave an
answer and then I'll finish up uh with
uh one kind of metaphysical
um question that I love to ask my my
guest so the first two these two
questions are for Andre
from Alan Lightman not Alan Guth if the
universe is infinite does that mean
there are an infinite number of Andre
lindes out there
well I would say one is more than enough
okay but but seriously uh you know uh he
of the University
infinite or like it is so reproducing
whatever stuff Quantum cosmology then
yes everything can be repeated but uh
the question is whether it's
second same or arbitrarily close
it's just like if you have an electron
you have a similar electron but then
probably what tells you that there is no
uh identical electrons in the Box okay
they're always slightly different okay
so when you say whether you can
make a Xerox copy of itself there are
some theorems about
impossibility of quantum cloning I would
be unable to Quantum clone myself even
if I had enough money well so that's the
thing so the the question is actually
very deep
so the answer is superficial depends on
your purpose why uh if for example you
think that anybody kills the second
unreal in the and I remain here no it is
not going to work okay
very good and then his uh his last
question before I asked my last question
is how would we prove the existence of
other universes in the Multiverse
but um I I will tell you two things yeah
uh the first thing is that one of the
main mechanisms which allow us to talk
about Multiverse sensibly is the
following we study this theory of Galaxy
formation
which is due to Quantum quotations
okay
these Quantum operations
uh let's talk about sharing your cat for
a second
okay so showing your cat
uh can be dead or you can be alive after
a certain experiment okay and then for
100 years philosophers fighting with
each other whether it is that when I
open the cage and I registered it dead
and then reduce that function the way
function for the dead cat always it was
healed at the moment when the experiment
started the fixed time but the uh live
copy of the cat is the second universe
and that cat is here because the
unitarity of quantum mechanics these
allows a wave function Branch disappear
so it will be many Universal
interpretation so it's 100 years okay
what is different about Quantum creation
of galaxies is that there was no cap
E I mean you start with the universe
where no galaxies and then the Galaxy
appear in one place or another place you
have this uncertainty it is described by
the wave function of the universe and
this wave function of the universe has
this many many branches and they do not
start even with the branch containing a
galaxy galaxy was produced from nothing
so a Galaxy can be here or here it can
be to the right of me to the top of me
there were maybe two galaxies to the
left the positions of the galaxies is uh
statistics okay this Statistics is
described by the wave function of the
universe this interpretation
the most consistent interpretation many
world interpretation of quantum
mechanics or many world or or okay but
now in this world already because the
sinusoidal waves uh perturbations they
produce
theologically at every wavelength
separately
they can be in any place or the size of
the Galaxy one wave comes with amplitude
up another way come with amplitude down
so it is like uh this deep touching your
coin at any place in the universe this
is a Multiverse this is Multiverse of
all possible
galaxies
this thing seem to be crazy now add to
this action field
extremely light field does not do
anything except for it has slight
potential energy
if this potential energy is too large
we have a large
Dark Matter okay
you make wonderful operations this
Quantum fluctuations put these options
to the top of the hill in one place of
the universe they're both in another
place of the universe so the dark matter
can be large and not large in the same
part of the universe don't call it no
diversity
What Makes You Suffer but that is
retrieval calculation the same
calculation which already confirmed
gives correct results for the galaxies
so if the same calculation is applied
for actions if you find actions in the
lab
then you know that this is what is going
to happen to them okay and then the
universe will be divided into places
where Dark Matter takes different values
take actions with very very slow slope
of the potential
then it will not move it will play the
role of dark energy
the value of their energy will depend on
where this Quantum operations produced
by inflation plays it there is nothing
dramatic like string theory landscape or
anything so what I'm saying and Max
Denmark's thought it was already but I
guess not many people took it seriously
if you have this Theory explaining
creation of galaxies in quantum
mechanics and this may be inflation or
maybe a periodic or whatever people stop
start cranking each other theory for
that because if they start using this
tools for describing what we already
know if they use them correctly and if
they put their ingredients which are
normal physics like actions to their
theories then you'll have Multiverse for
free the same tools so then they'll
prove the Multiverse
what are you talking about you take your
theory you trust your theory
any of these theories
so it's indeterminate right I I
understand that
um well Andre I have one one question I
normally ask four questions at the end
but in the interest of time you've been
so uh gracious with your time I'll I'll
just ask one so here at UC San Diego we
have the Arthur C Clarke Center for
human imagination and I'm the uh
associate co-director of that
institution and that's why I started the
podcast many decades ago and it feels
like a decade ago with uh my first guest
was Freeman Dyson and uh that was uh
quite lovely and and uh Miss Freeman
very much uh and I I've become
accustomed to asking several of Arthur C
Clarke's famous statements to my guest
and the one I want to ask you is the
following Arthur C Clarke said the
following he said when an uh when a
distinguished but elderly scientist says
something is possible he is very likely
correct or she
when he or she says something is
impossible they're very likely to be
wrong and I want to ask you is there
anything you've changed your mind about
is there anything you feel like you've
been wrong about
um over your career uh as a one of the
most distinguished and and celebrated
cosmologists of of this generation do
you have any this that you may have said
were were impossible that turned out to
be possible or vice versa
[Music]
usually I'm trying to
say that in the Multiverse everything is
possible which probably means that I am
not yet pulled by creation
it could be distinguished I uh was in
This Old Man category when I was young
when I told that I will never be going
to be a cosmologist and that happened to
be wrong
very good Andre well uh I want to say
spasiba thank you so much uh it's been
so much fun
I want to do another uh part two with uh
but that's how the universe works
the story continues you know Winston
Churchill said uh this is not the end
this is not even the end uh the
beginning of the end but it's the end of
the beginning so uh we'll have to do a
part two hopefully in person hopefully
with Renata and uh it would be a great
joy uh Andre Linde thank you so much for
joining us today thank you very much
foreign